today I'm gonna talk about what is going
to destroy note but first a little bit
of background so this here's Ryan doll
you probably have seen his picture
blurry and by the end of 27 Ryan and I
worked all know G has a long time ago
sorry inform e 2010 or something until
2013 when he kind of quit to quit the
project but at the end of 2017 we kind
of got together again and we decided to
both quit our jobs and try to build a
machine learning framework for
JavaScript
we've just got to talk basically about
tensor flow yes that didn't exist at the
time and we were like no we hate Python
but we want to use standard flow so we
are going to do this the framework was
called propel but sure enough half a
year later Google gums around and Asia's
to our Thunder it tensorflow jsn you
know we're you know not very smart so we
couldn't compete with that but what we
had learned in the process is that it's
actually you know using nodejs has
become you know arduous especially if
you want to build like a complicated
framework and we you know we we just got
the itch we wanted to make something to
make using no J's nice again so I'm
going to talk about what is gonna
replace it first a quick word of warning
though this demo thing is very much
under development when I talked in 2012
about nodejs
it was three years old Dino is not even
a year and a half so you know if you
design airplanes you know like don't put
demo in it yet especially if you you
know there's MCATs and stuff there's
probably many bugs but we'll work them
out and this is just an early preview so
just in case you didn't know denno is a
new runtime for JavaScript and also for
typescript we really love typescript
especially if you're building libraries
it just takes away so much of like the
asserts and the tests you have to do and
we also want it to be a good
run time for webassembly although
webassembly is a complicated thing
because you know in itself webassembly
needs to come from somewhere right so
I'm not going to make any claims about
that yet it's built on top of v8 just
like nodejs but then things are
different it's built on top of rust rust
is you might have heard about it is the
cool new thing and it is you know it is
hard to use but once you master it it
makes it a lot easier to build fast
integrated compiled software it's real
on top of Tokyo so I've spent a lot of
my years working on libuv that's out of
the door we just use a library that
already exists and you know that's one
of the really nice things about using
rust you have these libraries and it has
typescript built in so if you ever use
typescript nowadays you will probably be
using you know TSC if you come you know
just wanted to use it standalone or tias
node if you do it with node or most
likely you have some build set up but
react or sorry with wet back or or
parcel any of those things we don't like
any of that we wanted to have it built
in and that's exactly the reason why we
want to make demo in the first place
no js' I mean it it is good but you know
the world and especially the JavaScript
ecosystem has progressed quite a bit
since it was first designed in 2009 so
nowadays for example we have promises
and async functions so you know why do
all these no J's API still use Kovaks we
have async iterators and generators but
in nodejs
you have the streams and then streams -
and streams
two and a half or three or whatever we
have a node.js has a module system that
works but clearly the future of module
systems is eggman script modules
and node has buffers and the world
nowadays and the browser has typed
arrays so you know the JavaScript has
language has moved on and then note in
itself has some problems too in
particular we do not like its module
system we don't like that NPM is
centralized we don't like that most
likely when you install a module you
will get hundreds or thousands or files
which are actually mostly not used when
you when you run your program we do not
like that no js' has no security model
so you know in in the browser we are
used to running javascript in a sandbox
and nothing can really go wrong but in
urges you know you have to basically
just trust whatever code you download
and as I already mentioned nowadays
building a modern node.js application it
usually involves like an explosion of
tools like grunge go that backpack Dawa
parcel type script years now etc and
probably years Lin whatever have you and
so that of course they will serve their
purpose I'm not saying that these are
bad tools but it's not very practical
that you have to like kind of figure out
all of them and make them work together
in order to develop an application so
demo is is the opposite then there is a
single execute executable and as types
they're built in as a first-class
language it does imports it uses modern
tech my script import syntax and you can
pull modules directly from the web and
that's the only thing it does as much as
we can we make api's web standard so
fetch crypto with like you know get
random bytes whatever on it blobs text
encoder and then inside the executable
like rebuild in all the tools you can do
bundle for you so you don't need parcel
we can do formatting so you don't need
prettier testing is built-in you
you can install your tilty scripts like
am/pm and install you don't need a
separate package manager will add even
more stuff later on like generating
documentation building and
self-contained executables or the
runtime and the code all built into one
one file so you can distribute is an app
store for example that is our goal of it
then oh well very obviously not
completely there yet where it's only a
year and a half old but you know we have
something this is what we have built in
already so bundle eval test we can run
the test that you define in your code
and I want to show you a little bit of
like a demo program so just this is
hosted on our website it's just a very
simple example a file that uploads other
file a program that uploads files to
gist of github calm as you can see it is
simply put at a URL and we show it here
with nice colors etc because our server
sniffs out that you're actually visiting
it from a browser and so we colorize it
for you if you would curl this URL you
would get you just get plain text and we
also import a URL here or import another
module here and that simply comes from
another URL no shenanigans no npm
install so let's see if this works
actually yeah i want to upload a file to
gist so let's check that i actually have
a file to upload and let's see that we
can actually run directly a program
that's hosted at this URL
now i told you jeno has a built-in
security model so it's going to complain
to us hey you know you need we need to
give it access to the environment so we
try it again and we give it the
permissions
actually needs and if we're lucky this
is actually going to work and yes there
we go so this is you know if you can
copy this really quickly to your laptop
you can see that actually this file got
uploaded now of course as you can see
this is a very you know it's kind of
tedious to type all this stuff in
especially if you need to run something
over and over again so that's why we
have demo install we can say you know I
want to command
that's called just the gist comes from
this URL it needs these permissions and
oh there we go it's in souls it for you
and if we try it again we don't have to
type give give it the permissions again
then yes there we go
it can it can simply so we basically
just quickly installed a tool that was
on the website and well this I took a
screenshot after recording this so just
to prove that it actually works just
because we really want to you know bring
the way you write server-side JavaScript
and front-end JavaScript closer together
that means that you can also use some of
the built-in tooling that we have in
demo for front-end JavaScript so for
example this is a simple website let's
say for example website that actually
uses equina script modules and so what
we will see is that if we get the main
entry point which is bootstrap dog MJS
and we type demo info and we ask it for
some information about the URL that Evo
indeed just pull it down it will tell
you like nice module how how the module
structure is look is is built up we
could in theory do gano bundle for
example and that would just work but I
don't have the time for it to show all
that stuff there's one thing more that I
need to tackle about
or tell you about denno it's written in
rust so why is that really so special
well one of the big issues with Roth
with C++ which is both no jess is
written in is that you have basically
two options you write everything
yourself
so doesn't you know how chrome is
developed if Google writes everything
and then they figure out a way to like
glue it all together but as if you are
just too open-source maintainer x' then
you don't have time for that and that
means that you are going to use other
people's libraries and spend basically
all your time on maintaining the build
system because in C++ nothing ever works
together and everything like this
project uses C make and like v8 uses
nowadays GN which you probably have
never heard of and then there's VC PKK
PKG etc etc and that makes it very very
tedious to you know build on the
shoulders of giants as they're using you
sustains science in rust this kind of
has been figured out you can just you
know kind of like NPM add a so-called
create and you get all this
functionality which is why we didn't
have to write libuv because you know
it'll something like nvidia already
existed and we can just you know jam it
in there why we don't have to write an
HTTP parser because a CP parses for rust
exists and there's another advantage to
to it which is denno itself can be a
crate with no js' of course no jess is a
very useful tool but sometimes you want
to run v8 or v8 plus some extra features
inside a different context very well
known one for that is electron for
example building electron is actually
quite complicated but it's not just the
electron where you might want to do that
for example if you want to build
functions as a service cloud runtime
think I was on lambda or cloud for our
workers or what have you
your if you put if you want to put v8 in
there then you're going to have to do
a lot of work you can imagine a data
database where you have stored
procedures that are written in
JavaScript you can imagine game engines
that you can script with JavaScript or
you know office productivity tools with
a macro language which is based on
JavaScript all that stuff nowadays
requires that you basically figure out
everything yourself abetting know jazz
is really hard and so we're building
demo in a way where you can basically
pick little components of it and put it
where you need it so you can think of
you know I'm gonna put Dino in my
database but I don't need access to the
file system that makes no sense the only
thing I need is you know basic
JavaScript execution and you know access
over you know a local socket for example
it's just an example but we really want
to make it easy so you can get creative
and so we are starting to do this the
the final breakdown in modules is really
not there yet but as you can see we have
ten modules published and eight of those
or so are actually part of the the
current version of Nano and these these
like little pieces can help you if you
want to put your JavaScript engine
inside something else ok I told you
denno is not done by any means but you
can download it and I would really
encourage you to do it we were hoping to
release one zero by the end of the year
now the end of the year is really close
so I'm gonna say January ok if you don't
mind and one zero is also just a number
but it signifies something which is that
you know we we wanna kind of cut back a
little bit on like the rate of change
I'm breaking API so much and etc etc so
what are we trying to put in there well
we want to improve awesome support a
little bit so basically we can tell you
like oh if you want to use
assembly this is how you build it this
is how you import it etc etc it works to
some extent right now with this story is
no end-to-end complete I told you about
breaking it up breaking up demo in
different crates
basically we want to break every single
binding and a binding is like you know
file open fetch I don't know anything we
will want to put all of them in separate
crates so that you can really like
decide which ones you want and which
ones you don't want there's a few more
things web crypto needs to be completed
documentation needs to be improved we're
working on a better rust binding for VA
and I don't really have too much time by
the way to go over all this let's talk
if you have if you want to contribute to
it let's talk after after the break
denno is a really an open collaboration
so these are these are our top
contributors right now your name could
be up on this list like basically the
top row is the people that are like
super active but there's a lot of people
that are you know sometimes around but
you know this is not a project that is
saturated where there's a lot of drama
and committees yet so you know if you
have time on your hands please please
please you know look into it and see if
there's something fun you can do and
this is where you got all the
information about it oh yeah and I
wanted to show you this picture again
this is book dunno book to that they
made in Japan thank you very much for
your time
[Music]